We've been waiting for weeks and it is happening.
The house today is expected to vote to send
articles of Donald Trump's impeachment to
the Senate.
This is the first step in starting that Senate
impeachment trial of Donald Trump, which in
all likelihood is going to lead to Donald
Trump's acquittal by the Republican controlled
Senate.
At which point the question will be, does
that acquittal bolster Donald Trump's chances
of winning in November or does it hurt Donald
Trump's chances of winning the house also
is expected to name impeachment managers who
will prosecute the case.
We may already know who those managers are.
By the time you watch this clip or listen
to today's show, that decision may have already
been made according to NPR.
Following today's vote, the house will inform
the Senate.
It is ready to transmit the articles across
the Capitol.
The Senate will respond that it is ready to
receive them and a formal procession and reception
will take place.
That could happen later today.
The trial again based on what we know right
now expected to start in less than a week
on Tuesday, January 21st that means we will
in all likelihood have to reschedule the David
Pakman show viewer tournament.
Heartbreaking to many in our audience.
I know I will have more information about
that by the end of the week.
Republicans are of course already trying to
limit the witnesses that will appear.
Republicans are talking about uh, having some
portions of the trial completely behind closed
doors clearing the Senate chamber.
So that debate is going to get very interesting
very quickly and there are also a ton of new
documents that should be part of the impeachment
trial that are explosive, which I will talk
to you about a little bit later.
This is only the third time in history that
there will be an impeachment trial.
Andrew Johnson, bill Clinton being the other
two.
Remember that there was no impeachment trial
against Richard Nixon.
Nixon resigned before being impeached after
he knew he had lost the support of the Republican
voters and of Republicans in the Senate.
He would have been impeached and convicted
and chose to resign to avoid that.
The difference, one of the differences between
Nixon in the 70s and Trump in 2020 is Trump
has Fox news, Trump has social media.
Trump has one of the most low information,
electorates to put it lightly that we've seen
in a long time.
So Trump has and likely will not lose the
support of his sycophantic base, nor of the
Republican Senate.
A very different scenario today than what
we had under Richard Nixon.
So just a short update, this is happening
more than likely tomorrow.
Once we know who will be managing impeachment,
the parameters of it, the expected duration
of the trial, tomorrow we'll have more of
a plan for how we'll be covering it, what
to expect.
Maybe we will start to get a sense of which
witnesses will or won't be included, what
documents will or won't be included.
Uh, and that is exactly what we have to talk
about next.
The new documents that we are now
aware of.